[Music]
by the way fantastic that was doing that
was it tense for you to try it's very
tense that song III never enjoy it yeah
I yeah it's not nice
the I'm curious about something you
obviously he'll be there throughout the
interview I just need to know where he's
at now I'm safe I'm home I'm in my happy
place
yeah and your cold I know that's the
other thing my hands get cold you get
cold playing no I don't know I love cold
playing all playing the verb to Coldplay
via it's to just relentlessly were they
how do you find it here in America that
the crowds how is it different say you
performed in Australia performed
throughout the UK American crowds do
they get you they like think so I mean
when I first started doing here or
considering touring here all my English
friends ago you're really sure they're
really conservative and they don't get
irony and all that sort of stupid thing
that the Brits have a sort of comedy
snobbery because they are incredible
it is an incredible comedy country that
they're absolutely bathed in a but it's
it's bollocks that I it's I know it's
very little difference indeed especially
with my audiences cuz I talk about sex
and God and death and stuff and they're
quite universal things I'm not talking
about all back in West Australia don't
you hate it when the buses you know it's
not right it's not it's not hate those
West Australian bus yeah well I mean
your bollocks in Australia you're famous
for hating our buses well you've had
anyone protest any of your shows anyone
take offense and get really angry well
no I haven't had any protestors I really
I'm working on it but I they won't come
I did I did a gig in Texas in Dallas the
guy we were hiring the piano I always
plan way in advance to get a good piano
for my shows and the dude obviously
agreed to the hire and then YouTube me
and sent me this sort of ranting hate
email you know you can tell by the
overuse
of capitals how mentally kind of trust
me I know
yeah yeah an exclamation mark the the
subject heading of the email was
canceled exclamation May 10 he 10 wait
he wouldn't rent you the piano he
wouldn't in fact in his words not for a
million dollars hahaha and he signed off
loving Christ which was pretty awesome
but but I did I wanted to send an email
from Jesus he's famous for caps-lock
I did want to offer him a million bucks
because I respect someone who because of
their own moral you know whatever
decides they don't I wouldn't want to
support someone who are saying you know
doing a whole lot of homophobic jokes
for example I wouldn't hire my piano
john west for a baptist church so i
respected him but I did want to test his
resolve by actually saying ok million
dollars are and see if he still said
hahahaha where they said alright my
loving Christ doesn't matter so much
money would take the million yes